we've been talking a lot about Bernie
Sanders lately we've been talking a lot
about Joe Biden and how he fits into the
2020 Democratic primary we talked
yesterday on the bonus show about how
Beto O'Rourke has almost totally
disappeared from media coverage and his
polling is down as well from the 8 to 12
range Beto is down to as low as 3% in
two recent polls but what about
Elizabeth Warren Warren is doing some
really good stuff Warren is not only
starting to get some headway and
positive feedback in magic ountry at the
events that she's been holding she's
also pushed into the double digits in a
lot of recent polls and she's not doing
it with flash or charisma because as
I've said before I don't find her
particularly rife with charisma or
relatability but she's doing it with
policy proposals that are really
interesting many of which makes sense
now first of all lots of right-wingers
have been skeptical of Warren as some
kind of anti business anti
entrepreneurship type and she's really
not so when she shows up and talks about
letting entrepreneurs and markets work
in a controlled way that actually is
having some appeal across party lines
but she also has some really specific
and solid proposals that are strongly
socially Democratic and this is a lot of
the stuff I've been talking about for
years so let's look at some examples of
Elizabeth Warren's really great policy
proposals number one antitrust Elizabeth
Warren wants to pass legislation that
will require large tech platforms be
designated as platform utilities and get
broken apart or separated from
participants on that platform
she also as part of her antitrust ideas
would appoint regulators committed to
reversing illegal and anti-competitive
tech mergers really important and she
talks about protecting the future of the
Internet which is of course the
importance of net neutrality really
great stuff and I'm completely behind it
she's also proposed an ultra millionaire
tax and this would be a wealth tax on
the richest Americans and it would apply
to households with a net worth of over
50 million dollars so this is only about
75 households in a country of 300 and
million people it's the top 0.1% the way
it would work is you pay a two percent
tax on every dollar of net worth above
50 million dollars and a three percent
tax on every dollar of net worth above a
billion this is expected to raise nearly
three trillion dollars over a 10-year
period now I do have a concern about
this I'm unsure about this proposal but
it's a specific proposal and I think it
is fantastic that Elizabeth Warren is
talking really specifically my concern
about the wealth tax is that a lot of
that net worth that people have on paper
is not liquid and I don't think it would
be a good idea to enforce a tax that
might require rich people to sell assets
in order to pay the wealth tax and
that's just kind of like a question mark
for me I also have other questions about
whether we should be focused on wealth
or maybe looking at capital gains more
importantly but it doesn't matter right
like my exact opinion on this idea
doesn't matter this is a very specific
and ambitious proposal universal child
care the universal childcare proposal
that Elizabeth Warren has put out there
would see the government partner with
local childcare providers and childcare
would be free to anyone who is at 200%
of the federal poverty line or below and
then if you are above 200% of the
federal poverty line the cost of child
care would be capped at 7% of income it
would be paid for by the old for
millionaire tax that I just told you
about very interesting and important
proposal and there are positive
externalities of freeing up people to go
and work and earn wages that are good
for the government and they're good for
those families and it's a really
interesting proposal Elizabeth Warren
has a housing investment plan which she
says will bring down rental costs by 10%
over ten years and create a million and
a half jobs in construction and
renovation it would see the government
invest five hundred billion over the
next ten years to build preserve and
preserve and renovate units of housing
units which will be affordable to low
income families
textbook social democracy and she would
pay for it by a tweak to the estate tax
this is another very good proposal from
Elizabeth Warren you may remember that
when George W Bush was in office the
first seven million of an estate were
exempt from taxes that has been raised
to twenty-two million dollars Elizabeth
Warren would simply lower it back to
seven million dollars and also tweak
some of the numbers in terms of the
estate tax rates for people who have
really really big estates I could go on
there's many more of these proposals but
this is a sampling and what is really
important to understand about this is
that Elizabeth Warren is not changing
the capitalist system that we have she's
allowing entrepreneurship she's allowing
business she's allowing people to get
very rich and all of that stuff but
she's saying we're gonna use some of
that money to keep people from being
left behind we're gonna have relatively
modest government involvement a little
more in line with some of those Nordic
and Scandinavian economies and these are
serious specific proposals that go way
beyond what many other candidates are
doing or talking about so this is a
substance over style approach it may not
work right I mean she's polling third or
fourth depending on the poll that you
look at at a certain point if she's
going to be the nominee she needs to
start making more headway than she has
and I don't know that this substance
over style approach will actually appeal
to enough people Biden's for about
polling 40% and he's so far has been
running almost exclusively on Trump is
bad and I will defeat him which I've
pointed out is not a great way to run a
campaign Bernie on the other hand is
more in line with the progressive ideas
that people are actually looking for
when they are pulled fairly about what
they think government should be doing
and he's polling 14 to 18 percent
depending on the poll and Warren is
putting out detailed policy proposals
that make a lot of sense
and she's polling like 7 to 12 so I
don't know
that substance over style is gonna get
you the nomination I don't know that if
it gets you the nomination that it will
get you the presidency very depressing
unfortunately but really great that
Elizabeth Warren is doing this and it is
appealing to some voters who are taking
the time to go to her town hall events
and listen to what she has to say let me
know what you think about her proposals
about this approach the show is on
Instagram at David Pakman show